[Musik]
im rahmen eines militärischen festaktes
in der bücherei brecht kaserne übergab
verteidigungsminister mario kunasek am
12 dezember 2018 50 gelände gegen die
lastkraftwagen an die truppe ihr
gestellt werden die lastkraftwagen von
dem unternehmen rheinmetall man military
vehicles in diesem sinne wünsche ich
ihnen meine sehr geehrten kameraden
hinter wir also quasi bedarfsträger
dieser fahrzeuge
alles hat eigentlich gute immer
natürlich auch eine unfallfreie fahrt
und insgesamt ein großes danke auch für
die auftragserfüllung und auch mit dem
neuen gerät mit der neuen fahrzeug fiel
soldatenglück insgesamt werden der
heeres logistik schule bald 140
lastkraftwagen zur verfügung stehen ein
wichtiger schritt im bereich mobilität
beim bundesheer er ganz wichtig für die
mobilität im österreichischen bundesheer
dass wir konsequent auch daran
weiterarbeiten diese mobilität zu
steigern und das freut mich schon dass
wir heute die ersten 50 von insgesamt
140 9 5 tonnen lkws übergeben können
auch die truppe übergeben können dort
oder die fahrschulausbildung stattfindet
und für fehler die leute hier sind viele
alte bekannte auch für mich unglaublich
guter tag und ein schönes ein jahr ein
schönes zeichen auch dass wir uns
modernisieren und gut aufstellen
[Musik]